hey y'all it's andrew couch here and
you're watching the tidy tuesday web
series
where each week i analyze a random data
set and try to teach you
a data science technique before i start
this week's data set
which is about australian pets i want to
say that i found that
in my youtube analytics that 53 percent
or the majority of you who are watching
are not
subscribed so i would recommend that you
guys uh subscribe to me
so that way you can have a update
whenever i publish
my weekly video so this is the
australian
pets data set it comes with three
different um csvs
one about animal outcomes animal
complaints and brisbane complaints
and one of you guys uh we're talking
about one of you guys said in the
comments that uh
you wanted to learn more about functions
so i thought this would be a good data
set to try to teach you
all about functions in the r and tidy
verse framework
so what we're going to do is open up a
markdown i'm going to call this
tidy tuesday functions and let's start
this
okay so i'm going to remove that
i'm loading the tidy verse
and then paste this stuff in and we'll
run these code chunks using
ctrl shift enter okay
so let's look at animal outcomes first
just do a brief skim
just shows year animal type type of
animal
outcome for each animal type and then
what what that value is
i mean i guess in these regions pretty
cool
um let's do animal complaints
and we'll type complaint type okay not
too interesting
if you notice that these columns might
give us some problems
and then brisbane complaints not too
exciting
i'm curious what the csvs mean but
nothing too crazy
so let's look at animal complaints
if you notice um there's space
in it so if i say select animal
type it's gonna give me an error instead
i'm gonna actually have to like
wrap it around with quotes so i think
this
will be a really good introductory um
area for how we can apply functions or
learn how to use functions
okay so what is a function a function a
function just
uh basically applies something to an
input
and then returns it and in this case
actually r doesn't even have to
require you to return a function but i'm
getting a little ahead of myself
so let's just create our first function
so i'm going to say my
first func function and we'll
say function and we won't even give it
an input
so a function framework is just you have
to write function
give it these little parentheses where
you would put in an input
and then you wrap around these uh
brackets so in this case i'm gonna say
uh print hello world
and this is our first function so we got
that and we'll say
my first function prints hello world
okay so how can we use functions
um with this data set for example right
here
we want to change these column names i
want to change it to what
uh what was it so like this where
everything's lowercase and it has
it switches the space with the
underscore i'm fine with leaving
act and sw and stuff like that because
they're they're regions
um and it seems like uh that's as good
as this
distinction i could also turn change
total but i'm kind of fine with leaving
total as a capital
the big thing is to remove these uh
these spaces and switch them out with
these underscores
okay so what i can do is i can use the
rename
all what this does is we're going to
rename all the columns
and we can pass it a dot funds which is
a function
and we just specifically say function
but in this case um we need to give it a
input which will say dot x and that's
kind of like the default thing
so your first input could be dot x your
second input could be dot y
um if you're putting in a just a data
frame it's going to just say df so
there's some naming conventions but you
kind of name it whatever you want
in this case i'm going to name it.x
because that will represent each column
name
so i'm going to use a pi function
function too i'm going to say
okay for all these column names on a
lower i'm going to convert it to a
lowercase
and i also want to replace the space
i saw say pattern equals uh space
and replacement is equal to underscore
and that's what it does it lowered all
of the column names and then replaced
any spaces
with a underscore and what this function
is called is a lambda function or a
helper function
so i'm going to say this like um
clean data using a helper slash
lambda function cool
so one of the big ideas though is like
what is uh
how does r play a role in this well r is
considered a functional programming
language
so for example if we look at like animal
um
animal outcomes oops outcomes
r is basically all functions you know
you don't really write anything else
so for oops so for example mutate is a
function
uh uh scr is a function print is a
function we're always using functions
in r um
so how do we how can we apply
um a function that will start like
manipulating data
okay so one thing that i was looking at
right here is that
all these regions are not in a
percentage format or a decimal format
and i think that'd be kind of a helpful
way to look at it
because i don't want to look at you know
610 and then look at the total i think
it'd just be easier to divide everything
by
by total and one way you could do this
right
is you could say we could say like okay
mutate
act equals ht divided by total
uh nsw equals nsw divided by total
and go on and on and on that's not a
very smart way to do it
um hadley wickham says that if you're
basically
uh if you're re uh repeating a function
or something
like more than 10 times then you should
probably pass into a function
so that's what we're going to do and in
this case i'm going to say
uh convert to like decimal
right and we're going to give it a
function and we have to
kind of think about okay what inputs do
we need for our function to convert
something to a decimal place
well first we probably want the value
that we want to convert that value into
a decimal
and also the total right
because that's act because we need to
divide you know this value divided by
the total
and then what we can do is we can do
return and we say
value divided by total right pretty
straightforward
um but that still doesn't really help us
right if you think about it
um oops value divided by
total because if we still do this if we
say okay well
you know it's not really helping me
because then i still have to repeat
so like nt equals convert to
decimal nt in total
right not really great because that
means i still have to repeat it
um luckily r actually has a little
helper function for you
to apply a function on all the columns
and what that function is called is the
across function so what we're going to
say is we're going to say mutate
and we're going to say across and what
for a cross we have to give it
um the columns we want to apply a
function to so in this case we want to
apply it to azt to wa
and i'm going to say across right here
and what else we have to give it is a
dot
fns which is a little bit different than
dot funds
but they're the same thing they're
they're just saying we want a function
one thing with cross is you actually
give it the function inside of a cross
and then a cross will act as a function
in the mutate okay
so you want to so uh it gets kind of
confusing because like usually when you
do
use mutate you put the function outside
of it right there so you say okay across
these variables i want to
apply this function but across you have
to give it everything in there
and just put it into a mutate um so
we're going to give it
a tilde for the function and then we'll
say convert
to decimal value equals dot x
in this case dot x will represent all of
these columns
and then our total will equal to total
and what'd that do it applied on
this convert to decimal function to all
of the
rows or all the columns that we wanted
to
right so that's a pretty good way to do
it so let's say like apply
function across columns using
a but if you look at this this is kind
of a confusing thing to look at you're
like well
what are we looking at here like this
this seems kind of weird um we can also
just make this
right here into a function so let's say
say
um convert all uh
conver area to
decimal right and we can give it a
function
in this case um we're gonna make this
pipeable so we'll say
create a function that is
pipeable pipe up full uh
pipe bowl that does
the same thing so when we're piping it's
always
saying like we're gonna pass this value
this value
into here and then you're gonna return
whatever is coming in
whatever you did into the next value so
then that means we're just gonna pass it
into a data frame
right and what we can do then
is we can just give it um
right our data frame and then we just
give it the uh
oh the mutate across
right and this if you think about this
is actually just using
convert to decimal function right here
so you always put this function
inside of here right so if we do that
we can do this animal outcomes
convert area to decimal and does the
same thing
but it's a little cleaner right so this
thing
um looks so this looks cleaner
and does the same thing
all right this looks cleaner because if
we're if you're seeing someone
um do this you might not be familiar
with r
but right here we know what it's doing
it's converting area to decimal
cool and what's kind of cool about this
is there's actually other ways to
create functions so we can say another
way
to create the same function
and actually learn this um so i'm gonna
i will actually run this from david
robinson so i can say tidy
area percent right
and what we do is we just pass this
thing right here
let's switch the df into a dot and we
can do that and if we try this again
animal outcomes tidy
area percent it does the same thing
right so that's pretty cool um and right
now
like all these things where these i
guess like three main functions of like
helper functions
basic functions and then using the
functions to do across
um different uh variables is pretty
useful
um and it's kind of that'll get you
basically 80
of the way there but sometimes you might
want to be able to
specifically specify as a column or
write out the column
that you want to um apply this specific
function to for example
like whenever we're doing like uh let's
see here um
um animal outcomes
say for example i want to just say
select
like outcome count
outcome and then just do a gd plot a s
x equals outcome y equals n
um create a column and then
you know do a chord flip
uh it's like
right this is a pretty uh standard chart
that i always make
and we know i'll say like we uh we yeah
we can do like a mutate maybe so like
mutate outcome equals reorder outcome by
and and
right this is a pretty straightforward
uh chart and i always make them
but what if i want to say instead of
using outcome i want to select oh i
almost like
animal type all right so that way i'll
have to you know
copy this replace all that it probably
makes more sense to make into a function
and there's that's where tidy eval goes
into it or tidy eval
where it creates functions where and say
okay i want you to do this type of
manipulation
on a specific column that i i i state
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna say create um
the create bar chart right and say
function
um and we have to give it something
first we have to give it a data set
and we also give it an outcome right or
give it a variable that we want to
select so i'm going to say
column var and a data frame
since column var is essentially going to
be like this select
it's going to be a string so what i can
say
um for tidy for i guess are to really
understand that
you know you're you're going to be
stating this variable and using it as
like almost a name
uh we're going to assign it again to
this other thing which is called
the n quo
com bar and this basically so uh it's
for
what the user is for the function to
understand that the user is in me typing
this
okay boom
i'm gonna clean this a little bit
okay so we're gonna switch this data
frame into that
and we're also gonna give this calm bar
into it
okay so outcome
um was it combar convar calm bar
and that's it right should be pretty
easy
but if we actually do it we might run
into a problem
uh let's say uh outcome and then we give
it
animal outcomes it runs into an
error because it doesn't understand it
right and that's why you have to add in
these things which is called a bang bang
okay and when you're doing assigning
something to a bang bang you also have
to add
a little colon behind it
so once you do that so we have to say
must add bang
bang also
use instead of oops
instead of um
for bang bang right and this stuff
you just kind of have to know it um
there's definitely some computer science
into it
but to be honest i don't really know a
lot about it um
and i think it's really out of the scope
if you do want to learn it
um i think there is a nice advanced r
for data science
textbook that you can read and really
understand these how this works and
stuff like that
okay
so let's see here um okay aes actually
also
cool so
let's see here we have outcome right
there and so on that what's
what's going on here maybe in fact you
want me i'll just remove that
and see how it works right here
interesting
okay
oh that's why i'm i'll come there we go
sorry i didn't want to pass any string
so uh yeah you can just say like outcome
sorry i was looking i was wondering why
uh why i wasn't doing what i wanted to
do because i had it into a string
um so yeah there you go we have outcome
right if we want to do something else
say like um animal type
it is animal type so that's pretty
useful right
um also i can you know obviously do like
oh i don't know
uh what is it um you know maybe minus n
and also do like uh fill
equals column var
and do that and then we can kind of see
a nice little chart right there
actually maybe i'll just do a regular
end okay and maybe i'll do a
theme legend dot position equals none
cool looks pretty cool
switch it and it does the same thing and
it's pretty easy to do it
so sometimes um if i if i show you
right here this function it's not really
returning anything it's just printing
something
and that's where we can do functions
that really aren't going to be returning
stuff
instead they're actually just going to
do uh specific things in the background
and where's this useful is it's kind of
useful for like automating
saving or batch batch saving um one
thing i would say is like oh what if
you're
you know subsetting a lot of um like
real estate data
and you want to send these these csvs um
to each state or city
um you wouldn't want to just kind of go
um line by line
save rename save rename and go through
like 100
cities that would take like two hours
and you'd be you'd be wasting your time
okay so let's let's figure out a way to
do this okay
um and i think brisbane complaints looks
really good about this
for example um we have this
what what type of charts would we want
to see first of all i think this
we could make something with the suburbs
right so let's just say
um filter suburb
is equal to i don't know sunny bank
and then how about we just say i don't
know let's just count the amount of
issues that seems like a pretty
reasonable thing or count
uh category right
so count the categories of stuff that we
want to kind of look at
um what else could we do um yeah i think
that's
i think that's kind of a a useful thing
so if you do like a
uh mutate category reorder
category by n
g plot a s x eos
category y equals n
gm com plus chord flip
plus theme legend dot
position equals none and then what else
we could do oh yeah and then we say i
don't know
fill eagles category
right so that's pretty good plot maybe
we want to do a drop n a
so drop n a oops drop
n and then
yeah that seems pretty pretty useful so
this is
a chart purely for sunny bank okay
what if we wanted to do this to all of
the suburbs we wanted to say okay guys
here's here's what's happening in your
suburb here are the main types of
category issues that we've found
ooh actually now i look at it what if we
want to say filter animal type
by also we'll say animal
type is equal to attack how many animal
attacks are we experiencing right
so attack on person attack on animal not
an attack menacing
i think that's something that a
neighborhood would really want or a
suburb would really want
but if we want to create this
for each each suburb and kind of save as
a pdf and send it to them it could get a
lot it could take a long
a long time especially if we look at how
many
uh suburbs there are right
so there's about 192 suburbs that's
that's that's almost almost too much
suburbs too many suburbs right
so how can we do this how we can do this
is we can just kind of make
a uh a function for this so let's just
let's let's create a function for it so
let's say make
a function that creates a
chart for each suburb and saves it
as a pdf right
so let's let's do it let's say save
charts
and we'll give it a function we'll give
it a
a data frame and a file name
and here's what i think we could do with
for this for example
uh let's say filter rate
here
so we have that let's count the
categories for each so we can say count
categories for each
suburb count the categories right
right cool um
and that's that's fine and then we can
just drop drop n a's so right here
is what we kind of want right and then
what we can do is we can do a
nest minus suburb
right and now what we have is kind of
like a suburb or like what we want to
call
the uh the pdf and then we have our data
which is what we want to put into our
actual chart
okay cool so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna give this
and throw in here so we'll say df and
mutate it
and do all this
okay and i'm gonna clean this up a
little bit there is definitely a fast
way to do this but
i'm gonna also do this while i think
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
give this to a chart we'll say uh
say a chart we'll say
i will say temporary chart we'll give
that
and then what we'll do is we'll just say
like i don't know uh
maybe we'll do like plus um um
gg title gdc title and we'll say like
paste zero file name
and then say um attack attacks
attack attacks right so what we want to
do is also save it so i'll just say gg
save
file name is equal to paste paste zero
file name dot pdf
plot equals uh uh temp
chart width equals 11
height equals
five units equals inch
so what what i want to do is basically
that chart that i created i want to save
into a pdf
named after that neighborhood and it'll
be an eight half by eleven pdf
that um that's uh that's gonna be a cool
looking chart
okay that's pretty useful um what else
what am i doing
so um so if we look at this function
if you think about it it's not really
returning anything right it's just
saving
um so that and if you use other
functions such as map
um let's see here let's go back here why
is it
we use some functions like map it's
actually gonna want something to be
returned
instead what we're gonna have to do is
use the function walk
okay and in this case we're actually
gonna use walk
two because we have two inputs
i also wanna do a mutate uh
suburb is equal to scr replace and then
uh we'll say suburb
pattern and then replacement just
because you can see how there's uh
i want to add an underscore to it okay
cool and now what we're going to do is
i'm actually going to make sure that my
uh my yep so i'm going to
set as working directory and then i'll
do the rco to editor and then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do the
uh walk two
we'll give it our data which is our
input which is our
df our suburb
and we'll give it our save charts
function
function hmm not found
so a common thing with it is like r not
really understanding
what's a variable and what's like a
random argument
so what i recommend is it will loading
up the
mag magnet package
and what's cool about that is it's
already included they basically have
uh they're the ones that create the
pipes but they also come with other
pipes which allows you to use this pipe
which basically uh kind of helps you
helps the walk function
discern what other names or the columns
you want to select
so we're going to do that instead
and let's see what it's doing it's going
to save all of these files
into a pdf of all 113 of them
okay so we're going to let that go um
obviously i'm going to remove a lot of
the pdfs so i don't commit it but let's
let's check our actual uh repo so i'm
going to load up the tidy tuesday
tidy tuesday and let's see what's going
on here
and we can see all of these pdfs that
were saved
right look at those pdfs let's open one
up
we can see that windsor attacks attack
on a person let's open up
say sunnybank you can see how they're
different right
so anything let's see look at uh norman
park
okay so you can see how this this is a
pretty useful thing right
uh you can see how like oh wow like if i
have a lot of these
reports or csvs that um
someone needs to that i need to send out
every every week
i can use these functions to basically
do these batch saving and basically do
all the legwork for me
that's basically it um i know i went
pretty fast with it but
the main ideas is um functions are all
about
doing things doing the main leg work
that you don't want to do
you know it's good for repeating things
it's good for cleaning up
your code to make it look simpler and
it's good for doing batch jobs
not all functions require an actual
input and not all functions require an
actual output
and what's necessary about it is if the
function doesn't require an output
you always have to use walk if it
requires an output
then you have to use map so that's it
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on